[Music]
so I have three things that I love in my
life which is you know games
communication and cars self-driving cars
are really like for me it's the next big
thing so there's already self-driving
cars on the road today I driving one
every day and I have to say I can never
go back it's something very magical
right about software controlling a
two-ton vehicle I think that I would be
really excited about is like being able
to build autonomous vehicles for
[Music]
self-driving car nanodegree and I signed
up right away there's a huge talent
shortage in the self-driving car space
there's all these companies doing
development work and not enough
engineers who are able to fill those
roles the lessons really helped me and
that in the Udacity course jump into
this industry and learned the basics of
how everything works it's all about you
know building right you're not just
learning in isolation it's not just
research it's actual code that you're
writing we're working with over 200
different partners from car companies
truck companies shuttle companies
software startups as well as
ride-sharing services who are all
looking for talent that can help them
bring their products to market
self-driving cause to me of this the
ultimate product right it changes
arguably the biggest market on the
planet it levels the playing field of
individuals to now have access to safe
affordable reliable transportation so
when I think about what I want to spend
you know the next decade or so of my
life working on moving a 2-ton vehicle
around the world autonomously kind of
ranks there at the very top
[Music]